hero
now that pucks a Tony I know why do I
even need a rule for this now that puck
- Tony Phil has seen his shadow
oh wait that's not old Trump's head I'm
sorry go on to the next one you're right
new rule Kim Kardashian muscle Kim
Kardashian must cover that up before she
really does break the internet in Kim's
latest photo spread she appears to be
outdoors smoking with no pants on an
image that appeals to men whose sexual
fantasy is catching a homeless woman
taking a dump in an alley I don't know
which is more embarrassing for Kim
constantly having to market her ass or
the cars lining up behind her waiting to
see the drive-in movie that's it big ass
knurl now that Isis has shocked the
world by executing a prisoner by putting
him in a cage and burning him alive
Texas has to admit its reaction was huh
Nero now that Jeb Bush has admitted he
smoked weed back in his salad days
chris Christie must admit he never had
any salad days
and I have to admit when I first heard
the phrase Jeb Bush smoked some dope I
thought Jeb killed his brother
no roll get a room
enough with the trophy kissing before
you suck the air out of that ball - guys
it's the Vince Lombardi Trophy not the
Vince Lombardi rest stop New Jersey
people will be laughing president in New
Jersey with my folks it's big new rule
when your news network is doing a
special about the Holocaust you have to
pick a host with a less Nazi sounding
name than Wolf Blitzer
and while we're at it you might want to
rethink your look back at Pearl Harbor
with host Tojo kamikaze